[Music]  this Halloween someone has come home to  Elm Street  they say that Nancy Pelosi can invade  your dreams and if she kills you in  there you die yeah that's just an urban  legend babe I actually a little old to  be believing in ghosts or yeah and she  doesn't want to play nice guys this is  the joke it's not funny don't you think  it's weird that three of our friends  died in their sleep last week it's been  hard on all of us that's not what I mean  I keep having these dreams  [Music]  what why why is she after us it doesn't  make sense  don't you see Pelosi wants that baby  Pelosi hates babies  hey hey Britney babe stay with me don't  fall asleep you gotta stay awake okay  Losey on Elm Street the nightmare  continues  [Music]